regeneron is FDA authorized it's not
approved it's authorized that's
monoclonal antibodies that's what Joe
Rogan used Joe Rogan did a video where
he's like yo I had covet I was feeling
really bad so we threw the kitchen sink
at it we did monoclonal antibodies we
did Z Pack we did Ivermectin and there
all these Outlets are insulting Rogan
over uh over Ivermectin when the first
thing he says was monoclonal antibodies
which is regeneron now my question is
there is an emergency use authorization
under general not full approval as a
treatment for people and I think they
recently authorized it for potential
prophylaxis meaning like you can take it
to try and prevent as well if people if
if so my question is if people really
believe Ivermectin is as powerful and
potential and potent as it is in dealing
with this
why wouldn't the FDA just give it an
emergency use authorization you know
people are saying that the reason
they're they're not you know taking
Ivermectin seriously is because they
want everyone to get vaccinated and I'm
like but regeneron's available and
that's what Joe Rogan and Trump and many
other people used and it works and or I
should say we believe it does and the
FDA says it can be used so why not just
do an eua for Ivermectin if they really
had the data to back it up why not ask
yourself seriously why are you so eager
for Joe Rogan to be sick with with covid
right like he comes out and says this is
what I did and it seemed to work and
people were like I wish you had died
instead like what is this the strange
desire for him not to have succeeded in
what if if someone if one of you told me
you had coveted and you ate a lot of
bananas and you were like in the next
day I felt great I'd be like that's
really cool like I don't know maybe
maybe bananas work so I don't understand
this Fascination like like they want him
to be sick to just not break the
narrative uh and it's very bizarre this
is something we've noticed people have
gotten so mean we've gotten to the point
where people would actively like wish
that you just disappeared one way or the
other like why that's it that's uh I
don't I don't know what's going on I
think I can answer I can answer your
question from earlier about uh why is
things like Ivermectin not being
emergency authorized if but other things
because it's the same the same question
give you the same a different question
give you the same answer is why is
Pfizer creating a name for the the
vaccine called Community for profit
because someone owns that IP and they're
going to make massive amounts of money
off the selling Community instead of the
generic version you can't make money off
of generic medicine yeah you not really
big money though you know you can't own
the IP so this Ivermectin stuff is like
some generic dollar of 20 I don't know
how much it costs but it's Dirt Cheap
compared to what but it is mass produced
by people and you I guess the problem I
have with this is you get you start
getting the argument that well the
studies must be faked it's like well so
here's what we have we've got a bunch of
studies that are that are are pushed by
uh that are that are propped up by a lot
of people about the efficacy of
ivermectin they show country by country
data and then you have many other
studies saying it's not effective and we
found nothing
I would have to make the assumption that
one of those like groups of studies
would be wrong or intentionally lying
and so I think we don't have to get
conspiratorial on it if we have data
saying regeneron is effective and Joe
Rogan took it and it worked although he
did take zpac and Ivermectin so you can
people might judge whatever they want to
judge obviously the media is claiming it
was the horse medicine the whole time
but if if we have you know data that
these things do work then I think it
makes sense to say we don't want to do
an eua on Ivermectin because it's
conflicting data right now so imagine if
imagine if they came out and there's you
know we had Dr Chris Martinson he's a
smart guy and he said that look at all
these studies saying it works and then I
was like look at all these studies
saying they found no nothing no change
no positive fact it literally had no
impact and you know the response we got
from him was basically like oh yeah well
those studies you know you can't those
are no good and I'm like I'm I can't
make that decision I'm not I'm not the
guy who did the studies I'm not a Master
of the Universe I don't know everything
I see the studies and I see conflicting
data now imagine you are trying to
recommend people because you want them
to be healthy and you can choose to say
this one's got conflicting data this
one's got data showing it's it's
efficacious and regeneron also which
would you recommend I think it's it's
you can either believe in in the like
the the malice of people and the profit
motive and the greed and assume they're
just lying to people about these other
medications or I think you can make the
least amount of assumptions and say
someone looked at it was like I don't
know if that one's going to work I don't
want to recommend it right yeah yeah
also keep in mind that companies that
are producing products for profit often
will not test against them intentionally
you know you don't have to spend the
money to do the test to find out
everything's bad and but if there's no
test showing it's bad then there's no
evidence that it's bad all the FDA
though right but we had a study on
timcast.com talking about the efficacy
of I think what was it moderna and
AstraZeneca we read a study and it was
like they worked against Delta that
wasn't a study that was done by the
companies so look I don't like big
massive multinational corporation I
don't typically trust them or massive
governments I think they tend to be
utilitarian I think corporations are
very driven by profit they want to make
money but I also think what am I
supposed to do as a regular person to
all the regular people out there who are
trying to navigate this world keep their
kids safe when it's like you've got
people for competing political interests
and tribal reasons trying to tell you to
do something or not do something and
that's why I tell people when it comes
to all this stuff yes I genuinely mean
it when I say go talk to someone your
trusted doctor and if your doctor is not
someone good find one you trust because
the culture war is tainting everything
and making it hard for people to
understand reality yeah so I'll put it
this way I don't have the answer I don't
you might you might have an opinion on
the answer I just don't have it I
literally don't but I think driving this
also and making people distrust their
doctor the CDC the FDA the government
Etc there is a huge lack of
accountability as we learn more about
this virus and what I mean by that is uh
early on we have to get hospital beds we
were building hospitals we sent a boat a
Navy ship up to Manhattan because
by this weekend we will have forty
thousand respirators we asked Ford to
stop making cars because we need we need
a hundred thousand respirate those
things never came to fruition but my
point is like how come we never hear the
CDC be like hey look early on we thought
this turned out not to be the case but
now we know that every time they are
asked about those things it's like we
are not false we never make mistakes and
so people don't trust no I completely
agree
um when I when I look at the CDC and I
Look At You Know Joe Biden brought it up
Tuskegee right actually he insulted the
Tuskegee Airmen which is something
totally different very different than
not the Tuskegee experiments but but he
brought it up referencing that there
have been things in the history of this
country that made people distrust
government boom I can respect that and
then you have people who distrust
massive corporations I can respect that
find yourself a trump supporter doctor
then like if if I'm not saying you're a
trump supporter necessarily I'm just
pointing I'm just speaking generalities
if you've got the Democrats who are just
like I the craziest thing is they tell
me you know Casey neistat he's a good
dude uh I think he's a nice guy but he
tweeted out that he just pulled up to a
parking lot and stuck his arm out the
window and I was like you didn't consult
your doctor about like I think that's
bad I think you need to do that and then
you have on the other side people saying
yeah well doctors are dumb and I'm like
then find a doctor who's not dumb like
you're not the culture war is not your
place to take care of yourself man
people are manipulating you you've got
people on in every possible faction
trying to convince you that their right
and should join them for some reason or
another and that means they're going to
try and get you to get you to trust
certain things and distrust certain
things and that's why I think individual
and personal responsibility across the
board that's what I'm all about so but
you know what doesn't help that is when
you have like last week 75 doctors in
California walked out in protest because
we're not going to treat the
unvaccinated
um you have a uh a clinician who
wouldn't give Candace Owens a Cova test
yesterday right because I don't like
your politics right so when the members
of the community with the Hippocratic
Oath are now violating that for politics
that makes people not trust pop not
trust the profession but I agree they
did so much those doctors did so much
damage to the field of medicine but
there are a lot of medical workers that
are protesting the mandates yeah so so I
think my answer is simple then like uh
it would you trust a conservative Trump
supporting anti-woke doctor
would you would you trust a doctor
that's confused by politics at all oh I
mean want their hands on me if they're
thinking about Joe Biden we we've had
people on the show who have talked about
how their doctors are like
staunch conservative Republicans and
Trump supporters and if and gave them
all the pros and the cons knew all the
stories knew all the data knew what the
CDC had been saying about alternate
treatments and then made their
recommendation
I I I I think we've reached a point
where the culture war is so entrenched
in every aspect of every institution
it's very difficult to navigate this
stuff my fear is just that like you know
I I go on social media
and I see the horse medicine thing where
they're like smearing Joe Rogan as if to
imply that Joe Joe Rogan went to Tractor
Supply and bought you know some some
tube of what's called like Aver
avermectin paste or whatever and then
you stick it in the horse's mouth that's
not what Joe Rogan did Joe Rogan's a
very wealthy celebrity I'm sure he's got
a team of doctors and they showed up and
he was like heal me and they were like
yes sir and they started to go no I'm
sure he went to the doctor and he was
like what should we do and they were
like let's throw the kitchen sink at it
to imply that he went to a tractor
supply instead of a Walgreens first
prescription is insane and it makes
people distrust everything and
you you can't let the political agenda
and the manipulators
screw with you you know what I mean I I
think you've got to separate yourself
from the culture War you do your own
research you go and talk to a medical
protection practitioner someone that
your family knows and that you trust and
you have a conversation about it for as
long as you need to have it I think it's
also important is to not get triggered
by the misinformation because I I I want
to sometimes like it makes me kind of
angry but if just don't don't get angry
by it let it happen yeah it's the
confusion that makes me angry like I
feel confused and conflicted and then as
a result I feel angry but you see in in
in the culture War there is a goal among
I think it's particularly The
Establishment to be completely honest
which wraps up the Democrats it used to
be the Republicans but they when Trump
came in and broke the door down they
want you confused makes you easier to
control makes you frustrated scared and
say I give up and that's why I'm like
don't give up do research and then find
someone that you trust who's like look
if you do facts checking and you know
something is true and something isn't go
to your doctor ask them the questions
and if your doctor's wrong about some
like very obvious fact then you have a
bad doctor I I said it before about like
hiring a plumber who can't fix a toilet
like why would you want to hire that
person and I admire what you're saying
and I agree with what you're saying um
you are much more a non-partisan than I
am but I think part of driving the
culture War as I see it is heck last
weekend uh Deb Hanlon Secretary of the
Interior got married went back to uh New
Mexico Elizabeth Warren was there New
Mexico has a no more than 10 people
indoors masked at all times all these
photos leaked Senators the Secretary of
interior the governor no one's wearing a
mask they're all doing the chicken dance
they're all having a blast at the
wedding and it's like if you're the
enforcers of this law that is supposed
to protect us and you know just like you
don't really have to follow it well then
so I I get it like I I wish the culture
War wasn't so prevalent but when you see
stuff like that that I think tends to
come from one side of the aisle
I don't trust a lot of what's coming out
and it's hard for me to get past it I
mean it's hard for me to get past it
when you see that commonplace I'll say
that I trust the CDC and the FDA
substantially more than I would trust
the press or any one of these government
officials or Barack Obama and I don't
have a lot of trust in government
institutions regardless of the CDC or
the FDA elected leaders I don't right
right I just don't but they're they're
so uh I I lean towards the benefit of
the doubt in terms of and and maybe to a
fault because I know the history of this
country I think I love the meme where
it's like if you trust the government
you haven't been reading history and I'm
like dude the challenge is for regular
people not for those who are hyper
partisan there's regular people who are
sitting at home and they're like I see
what do I do and it's like you've got to
get yourself away from the battlefield
where everyone's slinging ideas and the
news is constantly in conflict and
people are saying you're a liar and
there are people who are sitting there
watching everyone accuse each other of
being liars and I hear that they go both
sides are bad and I'm like that's that's
fundamentally false there is like
conservatives who disagree on certain
things but we'll be honest with you and
the left that has no visible principles
in many regards like particularly with
what's going on in Texas
and that's why I think people need to
remove themselves from it yeah and I
love in the culture War the amount of
Kafka traps we plant now it's like you
are a sexist and only a sexist would say
you're not a sexist and it's like wow
that's that's great so that's it like we
just deal with each other like that on a
regular basis now in the culture War you
can remove yourself to a certain degree
and what I mean is if if you don't have
faith in your doctor find one you'll
have faith in but what is for instance
let's say that you have a doctor a
series of doctors that just pair at the
same talking point without any proof for
instance my wife is pregnant we go to
the doctor is the vaccine safe the
doctor says the vaccine is safe and
affected for and effective for pregnant
women but if you go to the FDA website
and I saw this this is after the
approval and uh this is uh let me pull
it up here
and it says
fda.gov
let me try Google search available data
on co-mernity you have to slur when you
say that available data on community
administered to pregnant women are
insufficient to inform vaccine
Associated risks and pregnancy and it
goes on to say that there's no evidence
that that immunity is going to be passed
on through breast milk but the doctor
will say that you know so what do you do
are you just stuck in a state of
confusion and you don't know what to do
I mean I I mean that's a that's a
legitimate concern that I have did you
show the doctor that data from the FDA
no no this was months ago when the
doctor said that but this is just a
brand new document that came up after
post approval so this is uh fda.gov we
have it right here it says available
data on community administered to
pregnant women are insufficient to
inform vaccine Associated risks in
pregnancy a developmental toxicity
toxicity study has been performed in
female rats administered the equivalent
of a single human dose of community on
four occasions twice prior to mating and
twice during gestation these studies
revealed no evidence of harm to the
fetus due to the vaccine and then they
have animal data so it sounds your
wife's not a rat right just making no no
no no no but I can thanks for asking
though yeah so so this is simple if if
you go to a plumber and you say
something like you know the pipe in the
back of my toilet is broken and he goes
what do you mean a pipe they use small
miniature aqueducts you'd be like that's
the most insane thing this guy's gonna
do was talking about right so if you go
to a doctor and he doesn't he hasn't
actually read the stuff like well I
would think that he would at least try
to protect himself legally and say
there's no evidence at this point in
time to say that this that it's not
effective or you know but he just
parroted the talking point you know and
I think that there's a lot of that
happening and I don't think that these
doctors are necessarily malevolent I
think that they just might be to some
extent ignorant it's interesting it says
there's insufficient uh they said data
available data is insufficient to inform
vaccine Associated risks in pregnancy so
right I you know but the FDA did say
that it was safe for pregnant women the
fives are safe and effective uh I think
all of them say that yeah yeah I did say
the FDA said it was safe and effective
than the FDA said it was indetermined if
it was safer effect this is the packet
insert so what I have pulled up this uh
20 Page thing is like what they give you
when you receive the uh you know the
vaccine warnings and precautions adverse
reactions and I gotta be honest the
adverse reactions are overwhelmingly
like your typical vaccine reaction it's
like you get your headache and then
you're sore arm for a day or whatever
that we get we've gotten vaccines before
um but but it does say that so I guess
my only concern is why the the Pfizer
insert is conflicting with what the FDA
is advising and that's why I just say
like
I can't explain it to you and you
shouldn't expect me to and I don't think
it's responsible to go to internet
personalities to try and figure this out
and if your doctor doesn't even know
about this it's very very difficult you
got to bring it to the doctor and they
often don't have time or interest in
reading it but sometimes they do and
they'll learn and they'll be like oh and
then they'll start teaching their
patients the new information I just I
just I think it's time to take
responsibility like the idea that you
could just go to a doctor and assume
they're they're they're good at their
job the idea that you just go to a
journalist and assume they're telling
the truth no no you gotta find good
journalists you got to do your research
you got to fact check now you got to go
and actually seek out those
professionals who you know and trust who
are going to take care of you the
novelist that's not me the novelist John
Gardner said something I've never
forgotten he said 87 of all people in
all professions are incompetent so to
find that 13 you know you gotta dig you
got to work wow well I mean at least 50
or below average right yeah literally
actually one of my favorite statistics
that I was there is a statistic of
something like 73 of Americans think
they're above average looks it's like
well
a lot of math problems right there right
so yeah I guess you know 87 is that's a
daunting statistic I don't know not
totally I think it might be accurate
thanks for checking out this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time